now more people working from home plus
low interest rates has made the u.s
housing market a very competitive place
right now in 2021 home prices grew at a
record pace surging to a 15-year high if
you put your house on the market last
year you're almost guaranteed to get
multiple offers the national association
of realtors says a total of 6.1 million
homes were sold and home sales are
falling off now if you look at greenwich
connecticut for instance sales fell 36
but that's because there are precious
few listings on the market so what's to
come jonathan miller is president and
ceo of miller samuel real estate
appraisers and consultants and he joins
us now with more jonathan great to speak
with you we've got extremes in both
supply and demand i want to hit on the
supply part first there's just not
enough of it why is supply so so low
right now because even in previous
housing booms it never got to this point
people who wanted to buy a house were
selling their house first what's
different this time
so i think what's different is that uh
despite uh you know if you think about
the 30-year fixed mortgage was about
five percent back in 2018 and during the
pandemic it felt almost half that and
it's up a little bit from there
so i don't think people are giving
enough credit or to the power of demand
that has been thrown on
the housing market in the middle of you
know a relatively robust period that
we've had aside from the quarter during
the initial uh moments of the pandemic
in and prior to the pandemic so it's
burned off supply much faster than being
created and most of the new construction
new development that's being built is
skewed towards the upper half of the
market so it doesn't solve the problem
and is only maybe 10 to 15 percent of
the national picture in inventory most
of the inventory is existing
existing properties well should we be
thinking of this as a pandemic specific
problem or is it bigger than that is it
going to be more long-lasting
so i think
you know part of this
was initially the pandemic but i really
look at the pandemic as the catalyst to
remote work and
the uh essentially the relationship
between work and home and
and that's all being recalculated right
now uh and so we're seeing that in
housing behavior around the country
where you know there are people that can
live farther away
uh from the office than they they used
to be able to and that's set certain
housing markets on fire you know poor
proper probably use of terms but really
you know the demand
they haven't seen certain markets where
that are further away from cities
are booming because and they don't have
traditionally the supply one important
point about inventories think of
inventory existing inventory 85 percent
of houses out there is this living
breathing organism based on people's
life cycles and you throw
incredibly low rates at it for a
sustained period of time you it can't
replenish fast enough and so now we have
we don't just have low
uh inventory we have unbelievably low
historic low by a long shot and that is
creating havoc in the housing market
okay but you mentioned low interest
rates interest rates are set to rise
perhaps later this year i wonder whether
that will have any material impact on
what we're seeing in housing when so
many of the buyers are all cash buyers
and therefore it doesn't matter whether
interest rates are high or low or
they're institutional investors and they
have the means to be able to finance
whatever they're buying
yeah and also if you have another uh
covid variant
that'll temper uh you know rate growth
uh as well so there's a lot of there's a
lot of uncertainty in that regard i
think the way i would think of it is
that rates are so low that even if they
come up there's concern about some sort
of correction or you know even some talk
about a bubble we have the tightest
credit conditions we've had in oh you
know relative to
the housing bubble uh this is not a lax
lending environment and and even if
inventory doubles
it's still low
so yes we'll expect inventory to rise as
sales level off but i think
that over the next couple of years on
the other side of this boom i think
we're going to be using the words words
like plateau or moving sideways as
opposed to correction simply because
there there isn't a surplus of inventory
leading into the housing bubble
there was a tremendous surge in
inventory but sales activity was growing
faster so the market felt really fast
we're not seeing that this time okay so
i've got to get your personal advice
jonathan i'm under 30 i've always
dreamed of having some type of property
ownership by the time i turned 30 it
feels like that's getting increasingly
less likely should i just accept that
the millennial generation is going to
become the generation of renters forever
absolutely not uh i have to get personal
i have four sons
uh they're the three oldest are all
millennials and they've all bought or
are buying houses right jonathan they
have you come on
yeah i i don't know if that's a benefit
or not but uh but but uh the way to
think of this is that uh you shouldn't
use the growth in housing prices as a
barometer of sort of an inflationary
barometer you should look at mortgage
payments and mortgage payments you know
in terms of principal and interest
portion of uh monthly housing costs is
not the whole thing so the rate of
growth is much lower it's still high but
it's much lower than what we're seeing
for prices themselves
but maddie brings up a good point and
that is housing unaffordability it feels
like it's already kind of extreme how
much more extreme is housing and
affordability going to be before i don't
know policymakers start looking into it
and actually doing something about it
so i i think that we're in a pretty
strong i i don't see any relief for in
terms of inventory coming back unless
rates really go up you know we start
talking about in the five percent range
which is i think where they should be
uh there's a tremendous distortion
called by very low rates uh but you know
the reality is that the leverage in
terms of
how much debt people have uh how
relative to household income now is far
less
uh
relative to household income than it was
during the bubble itself so again
housing prices are not the metric to use
in terms of affordability it's the
payment itself
how does the rental market compare here
what's leading and lagging i've noticed
anecdotally in new york that you can get
a lot more
from a monthly mortgage payment for
example than a monthly rent payment the
the difference is is really staggering
there
yeah so so when you think of the rental
market first of all in manhattan
and many large cities because the
economic damage from the lockdown and
covid was much more punishing to lower
wage earners and higher wage earners
what we're really seeing is a rental
market that's highly polarized so in
manhattan if you compare
the upper half of the market versus the
lower half by price the upper half rents
are up about uh on a year-over-year
basis they're up 30 percent but if we
compare them against two years ago
they're up about eight percent which is
ahead of sort of pre-pandemic conditions
if you look at the lower half of the
market uh rents are up about 11
year-over-year
but they're they're down seven percent
meaning they're seven percent below
pre-pandemic so it's a highly polarized
market in a lot of the
these stories about the market about 80
people waiting in line for one apartment
or bidding wars tend to be skewed
towards the higher end because that
economic cohort was
less uh savage by the pandemic wow well
said
you know we like talking to you because
you're an appraiser which means that you
offer an unbiased opinion on a home's
value and you're looking at the data and
looking at the value of the data and and
how it's changed over time as opposed to
someone who makes money off of uh just a
sale of a of a property so i'm curious
if you could walk us through how to drop
off in home sales and home purchases
because of the low inventory affects the
pricing of homes because if there aren't
enough transactions taking place there
aren't enough comparisons and we know
that sellers use comps when they want to
price their homes to put on the market
we know that buyers use comps when they
decide how much to bid for a home as
well
right
you're you're this you're making such a
good point that uh the problem is uh
that uh there is a extreme lack of uh
supply and so as a result what we're
starting to see now like in markets like
greenwich is you're starting to see
sales activity fall
fairly sharply and it's not because
demand disease it's because inventory
has literally collapsed where um we're
seeing you know in in greenwich itself
we're seeing inventory levels uh you
know down dramatically uh you know at
all at decade lows and and even further
um and so what's it what that will
result in is a lower level of
transactional activity which then makes
it harder but in the moment meaning
right now
uh
to use you know another personal sort of
uh story is one of my sons is
you know just put their home on the
market this week in connecticut and
there are eight listings
uh in the in the whole city um
and uh they got about 25 walk-throughs
people walking through within 24 hours
and they got bids that were 25
above a price that they set that was 20
higher than what they thought it was
worth
so uh it pricing is
we're entering in a period where pricing
is far more difficult than it was say
six months ago when there was a flood of
activity in the region
and there was a lot of inventory that
had built up during the pandemic that is
slowly being burned off in markets like
manhattan inventory right now one of the
advantage manhattan as a city has over
the surrounding suburbs and many
markets in the country is that it
actually inventory because it was late
to the party about nine months behind
everybody else because of the pandemic
inventory in manhattan is only about
five or seven percent below
long time no long-term noise there's
actually product to look at in the
suburbs that's not the story
i'm curious also about the buyers who
are out there um what do we know about
the different groups of buyers and how
price sensitive or perhaps insensitive
they are
are we do you see us getting to a point
in the next year or so where we might
reach a buyer strike where people say
you know what the prices are too high i
can't do this anymore and just sit out
yeah yeah
i think um and and you know there's a
saying i don't know where i got it from
but it's uh you know one of the best
solutions or one of the best things for
high housing prices are high housing
prices uh because what you have is you
have a market that we don't have
financial engineering of the bubble
we have conservative underwriting from
banks for the most part
and so
we're not looking at
sort of an orchestrated this is actually
credit quality is extremely high
and people reach a threshold and they're
not going to necessarily get variances
um allowances from lenders and they
won't be able to and that will check
sort of runaway housing prices and i
think 2022 is going to be a period of
rising prices but probably not at the
same level as the last half of 2021
and a lot of that is because of uh
uh lending uh standards have are still
relatively tight jonathan thank you so
much a lot to think about and i think
maddie is going to be looking at um
apartments yeah with a very very
skeptical eye for a while now presidency
of miller samuel thank you so much